this week we are partnered with
hellofresh and Rocket money more on them
after the
[Music]
reaction what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation I am joined with
Aaron Alexander we are going to watch a
movie that I've been wanting to watch
for a long time and I perked up when I
saw Aaron hadn't seen this either hidden
figures Aaron how are you I am doing so
good so great I'm ready for this movie
starring
terrari starring to Rari starring to
rajie P Henson if this guy thinks I'm
cutting that out and editing it to make
it look smooth he's got another thing
coming hey baby we on the Fly we do it
we we flub up words that's okay we make
it up leave a like on this video people
subscribe and click the notification
Bell and while you're at it tell us did
you like hidden figures is this a Hidden
Gem in your mind thank you to preer for
helping us edit down these highlights
full length Reaction watch along so you
sync up with your own copy of hidden
figures available first super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page we
cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included all right Aon you ready
to discover what's been
hidden the figures yeah I'm ready for
all the
figures yep yeah yeah baby it's going to
be us we're going to ruin the movie for
you guys Janelle Monet octavus Spencer
damn Kevin cner
yeah 21
West Virginia Collegiate Institute is
the best school for Negroes in the state
really that's right the only School past
the eighth grade anywhere near here
scalene equilateral she's smart rhombus
trapezoid
oh they want to take her early
tetrahedron she's like good at geometry
naturally is that what geometry is
okay math shapes that's all I know why
don't you solve the equation on the the
board she sees things differently than
the rest of us she's an
[Music]
X-Men but women in the 1920s can't do
math so if you move all the terms over
to one side you can put the quadratics
into a form that can be factored
allowing that side of the equation to
equal zero once you done that it's St
straight forward from there let's go
Little Nerd let go what the hell I've
never seen a mind like the one your
daughter has hurry on now love you have
to go she trying to make the rest of us
look
stupid you have to see what she becomes
Oprah she becomes
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oprah oh wow 40 years later
damn okay try to turn it open now there
a little jiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle that is definitely the star
starter is starting to make us late we
all going to end up unemployed riding
around in this Palace a junk to work
every day you're welcome to walk the 16
miles or sit in the back of the bus I
won't do NE a hitch High you know from
the little bit I know about this movie
this is a really smart opening scene for
the characters for what they're them
fixing this mechanical piece of
Machinery together okay no crime in a
broken down car no crime being negro
button it up Mary nobody wants to go to
jail behind your mouth I do my best
shoo ladies are you
black you have identification on yes sir
we're just on our way to work NASA sir
we do a great deal of the calculating
getting our rockets in space all three
that's crazy NASA I had no idea they
hired colorss you girls ever meet those
astronauts Mercury 7 absolutely we work
with those gentlemen all the time they
don't do they a never even seen an
astronaut we got to get a man up here
for the commies do that's was certain h
of service broken down on the side of
the road this cop's taking a l of them
what y'all need a toe or something all
you respected man they smart up the
Negroes okay by pass the
starter
yeah see NASA imagine you running late
to work oh no so we wouldn't want to
bother you that would be wonderful
officer follow me I'm driving hurry up
door these are three great actresses
they're awesome they're all three
amazing actors I don't even know where
to begin oh I tell you where to begin
three negro women are chasing a white
police
officer that's right that's right that
there is a God orain
Miracle oh what I wish she was able to
take a
selfie you just know this is the kind of
movie that's going to have the most
excellent props and costume design and
look at the colors popping
already Kevin cner pocket he's going to
be the only one in the thumbnail
second man we really got to beat them
goddamn
Russians we're about five minutes in
it's already better than Apollo
18 it's called Apollo 13 by the
way I rest my
case yes Mr President it looks like
they've achieved at least one orbit
maybe two when he answered the call of
the President Kennedy was on the back
we're about five minutes in it's already
better than Apollo
18 it's called Apollo 13 by the
way go again so is our comrade Ian a
dummy what the hell proven life can be
oh it's it's him I'm Dr Sheldon Cooper
OMG a damn dog and a damn
mannequin 1.6 Megaton RDS drops down in
the middle of De Mo well that's a pretty
big jump Paul Stafford our lead engineer
Mr web I think what he meant to say is
that speculation at least on our side of
the equation just a little dangerous
well said damn inaction and indecision
Russians indecision is a thief of
opportunity just so you know he's not
wrong about what he said in there you
know that right wow cool framing yeah
where's the machine in a day now Mr
Harrison what's it called the initials
the IBM it's lot this cool like wide
Center framing they're doing with almost
every angle I need a mathematician W
andest ah each one of them in their own
box that's cool I like that Christ we
don't have a single person in this
entire building that can handle analytic
geometry well tell me something else we
like we're going to find such a person
before the Russians plant a flag on the
damn Moon Russians we're Russian to beat
the Russians we know just the ladies to
do it I have no idea who these women
are Mr zalinsky is requesting you for a
permanent assignment are you serious get
moving o thank you Jesus oh thank you
Mary keep it inside Mary Jesus is right
there be
quiet Mrs Mitchell is that Kirsten dun
kirston dun is in this what the hell
space test group needs a computer ASAP
Computer someone with a handle on
analytic geometry we can't fill that
position out of the East group you have
someone I don't need to talk to him
Catherine's a g off of that she can
handle any numbers you put in front of
her I'll check her credentials she was
destined for great things and she's just
here a typewriter and I can't figure out
why my application for supervisor man
was just wondering if they're still
considering me for that position well
the official word is no they're not
assigning a permanent supervisor for the
Color Group may I ask why I didn't ask
why jeez we haven't had one since Miss
Janson got sick it's been almost a year
things are working just fine as it I'm
doing the work of a super B pay her just
fast with rocket ship slow with
advancement get those trajectory CS
worked out need it for the Redstone test
fast food rocket ships set low with
advancement what a crazy irony damn so
sad even in the field of science there's
still relegated to second class of
course yeah man science Community bunch
of pompous
[Laughter]
dicks go in there
turn on the
engine uh get out of
there what if they just kill off Janelle
mon right now oh my
god oh [__] what if they just kill off
Janelle Monae right now oh come on get
it one one moment forget it forget the
hill just run just get out of there 9 8
7 y'all ain't going to stop it for bro I
don't think it's that simple I I don't
think you just turn it off no one's
going to go and help her like why why
would they risk their own lives for
someone who wants to save a
shoe CU because of human decency I guess
what do I
know that's a great shot we alter the
exterior from smooth to corrugated the
capsule might have most
stability Shield erosion occurs on the
posterior side about in the Retro
booster the area closest to the boosters
is closest to the heat couples with
Rising temperature on
re-entry yes consider another fascin
other than the boat we
should
yes I'm I'm keeping up when I keep up
with movies like this it makes me feel
smart I know just as much as they do
it's almost as if I went to school for
this a person with Engineers mind should
be an engineer you can't be a computer
the rest of your life I'm a negro woman
I'm not going to entertain the
impossible let me ask ask you if you
were a wide M would you wish to be an
engineer I wouldn't have to I'd already
be one be one yeah skirts must be worn
past the knee oh this is going to be a
moving ass film I can feel it Aaron do
not talk to Mr Harrison unless he talks
to you things move fast around here your
clearance they've never had a color in
here before Catherine don't embarrass me
GH kick some rocks lady so weird you see
so many movies about racism you hear
about all the time but it never just
becomes like depending on who you are
it's not like an easy watch you know
yeah this wasn't empty last night I oh
screw you bro
C sometimes I just can't tell if they
treat her this way because she's black
or because she's a
woman or is it both I think it's a combo
sandwich double threat double threat
double underestimated Mr Harrison won't
warm up to you don't expect it do you
work keep your head down thank you oh Mr
Harrison's going to love her go on get
settled so did these three do like
something incredible and their stories
just been pushed down as history has
unfolded as I have no idea who we're
watching yeah me neither should and did
we make it to the
moon they got us there actually what's
the status on that computer she's right
behind you Mr Harrison she is the
computer does she handle analytic
geometry absolutely and she's
be you think you can find me the F frame
for this data using the Graham or
analization algorithm yes sir I prefer
it over ukian coordinates oh that's so
hot good then I'm going to need it by
the end of the day God I love intellect
I'm also going to ask you to check Mr
Stafford's math as well as others on
this floor from time to time I can
handle that out I'm sure you can Paul
shingles wouldn't be flying off the heat
shield now would they he really picks on
that guy in 14 days the Mercury 7 will
be here for training and I have no doubt
in my mind that they're going to be
asking us questions about our work
Mercury 7 on top of a missile shooting
into space and it's never been done
before done everything we do between now
and then it's going to matter I believe
it's going to matter to the whole damn
country it's pretty incredible when you
think about it man yeah the achievements
yeah how far we've come as a species
amazing less than a hundred years ago if
you tell people who went to the moon I
think you're out of your mind my numbers
are spot on I will double check them sir
no problem what an uphill battle one
must climb I'm not going to be able work
on what you can read the rest is
classified you don't have clearance I
mean that might just be at the level
she's at it might not have to do still
the undertones are there are they I
think you're reading too much into
it excuse me might ask what the L's room
is sorry I have no idea what your
bathroom is oh my God hate this she
might just mean the woman's bathroom Aon
[Laughter]
she oh yeah the pressure women's
bathrooms with the maintenance that's
outdated by 15 years she really need to
go to the bathroom or she like need to
cry or maybe
both I think she really just needs to go
to the bathroom yeah she's doing that
the the peee dance the this is so sad
the piss
breaths they're underground too but I
get whenever I have to poop in a
stranger's house do the same thing you
drive home drive home call an Uber
whatever it
takes
oh she probably get more done on the
crapper than anyone else H might yeah
Ruth where's that girl with the number
on a break we'll take breaks now so
messed
up just has do that every time she has
to go to the bathroom go all the way
across the facility I solved it I know
how to get to
space Where Have You Been are you
finished yet almost he say by the end of
the day the end of the day around here
was yesterday I need those done first he
wants those done first oh God and she
has to be so submissive I don't think
she heard you it's like hard to develop
agency
here yeah 60s being a woman being a
black woman being a black woman in
science I love how she's just so in her
zone now like she's so comfortable that
she's just in another workplace not even
noticing the people around her she's
actively ignoring it because she has to
I think she's just really in the zone
she's in her comfort zone
yeah she freak for a second see well she
cares about them numbers she's smarter
than all of you you dumb pencil
pushing dummy just
crackers hey man work late like this
prove yourself yeah un like Aaron wants
to get out of here right
[Laughter]
away yeah I just said you know and
Stafford he show CS you're the best one
you're better than all of them you know
what we're doing here trying to put put
a man into space sir that's right so you
can throw that in the trash why it's not
an insult to your work it's just
obsolete that's how fast things are
moving around here I said I was sorry
I'd be saying it all
day that's what I tell my wife what I'm
asking you to do what I'm asking
everyone in that room all my Geniuses is
to look beyond the numbers to look
around them that's what she does her
answers the questions we don't even know
to ask math it doesn't yet exist an
interesting way to look at it develop a
new mathematical system I don't need
another smart girl with an adding
machine can I go sir yes you can go he's
the only non-racist one in
the yep I wonder if that's historically
accurate I hope so I mean Kevin cner I
think he he'd object against playing the
racist I want no racist lines every is
racist but
me I'm I am the white Sav I am
good I Haven been late one day in 10
years haven't been out sick my works on
time it's done right it's done well it's
not fair that's a fact you deserve to be
a supervisor it's having the
responsibility of a supervisor but not
the title of the pay be told darthy I
don't even know if I can keep up in that
room why I'll be back with the computers
in the week or out of a job entirely oh
please the real struggles is they have
to overcome what's with an in just make
that pencil move as fast as your mind
does you'll be fine trust your intuition
I sound like a supervisor don't I a
meano saled one ridd with authority no
question these three have really great
chemistry yeah I hope they got along in
real life I'd hope so new assignment
space task group might be a slight
promotion but you want the job right
it's a challenge but it's nothing you
can't handle Catherine thank you
Mama oh fascinating she's got it all up
here but there's a lack of faith in here
yeah I a supporter for mom is too we
just wanted to say good night you've
been gone for 300 100
hours I know I work a full-time job now
you all know that I have to be mommy and
daddy damn I miss your father just as
much as anyone oh he died it's going to
be one of those
movies you could fly up to space if you
wanted to Mama did you draw this is that
me I love you baby oh she even got a
rocket behind her too older daughter all
right now this time really go to bed a
wonder if she pursues the same career
paths as her mom growing up got artists
in the family you got others who seem
just as intellectual as her that be
really hard being a mother of three and
working at Nasa oh man his faith in us
has no limit the good Lord has our very
own women or can own rocket
ships
and this what give a shout of praise for
Colonel Jim Johnson returning home by
the grace of God set up
see [__] new Daddy I don't care that
Daddy's dead you're probably
upgrading I don't I don't understand all
this Hodge too all this hod is in this
that's crazy damn it's like the black
Avengers
a NASA's never ever giving you g you do
having a couple extra degrees ain't
going to change that civil rights ain't
always
s ain't that the truth just a harsh
inner belief system I he he's don't see
any there well that's good for him go
find your way over there that Colonel
Jim is a tall glass of
water strong commanded oh and I bet he's
like that day and night Mary Sund please
it's Sunday it's time for an act of sin
is what I
say Praise Him in the
sheets he's coming over oh maraw Ali
must have the hidden figure you know
what I'm saying
are you singing as a big yeah yeah
singing subtle for YouTube purposes
jeez she's not married she's a widow
with three beautiful little girls so
well behaved angels on Earth is what we
like to call why you really son the
daughter Point here I love single
mothers really edifying that Pastor
mentioned you a computer at Nasa we
calculate mathematics necessary to
enable launch and Landing for the space
program that is really well easy to
understand pretty heavy stuff they let
women handle that sort of uhoh not the
sexism that's not what I mean it's
exactly what I
mean just surprised something so
taxing Mr
Johnson I mean no disrespect I mean no
disrespect let me top it off with the
third sexist statement you you can just
put that foot back on put that shoe back
in your foot I analyze the monometer
levels for air displacement friction and
velocity
and compute over 10,000 calculations by
cosine square root and lately analytic
geometry tell him his balls just fell
off and we're proud to be doing our part
for the country so yes they let women do
some things at Nasa Mr Johnson and it's
not because we wear skirts it's because
we wear
glasses hit so fine I mean I don't know
why why that came out of me I'm
sorry handsome must be a requirement too
how could you possibly be hling these
white men I always equal rights I have
the right to see fine in every
color that's John Glenn oh my God the
cast just gets better what do you ladies
do for NASA calculate your trajectories
launch and Landing you can't get
anywhere without the numbers no sir Mary
Jackson Mr Glenn engineering and I'm
proud of the devil to be working I love
the initiative she takes
yeah you got to be [__]
me they just had to have so much
patience back then they didn't even fill
it yall are the worst civil rights may
not be so civil Mr Harrison want you to
confirm launch and Landing for the
Redstone Rocket
test wow I cannot work on what I cannot
see Mr staff those numbers have already
been confirmed by two engineers in this
department and myself this is more or
less a dummy check wow wow underscore
that word
[Applause]
enough off the first page the first
thing you read she's that good you got
that
far what are
you she can read the hidden
figures I love the music they choose
almost goes it a bit of a film Noir
touch yeah singing
Jazzy
who directed this I really like the way
the movie is framed our runner can pick
up your work Dorothy you need to be
working not walking oh it's it's great
time you need something else I was
wondering if you know what they're
building over in the tech Wing it's
called an IBM a main frame machine
apparently it can do our calculations in
a fraction of the time replace
them is everyone just watching her she
got it off the first page they're
watching her like a hawk they think
she's doing graffiti
Greg what are those symbols and like
what are the gang signs you're writing
up there woman
[Music]
huh my
God she wrote on the white people's
[Music]
[Laughter]
chalkboard who work is that it's good I
love it Catherine goal
sir
oh man they're going to set you up with
like a porta potty right next to your
desk
now classified information it's top
secret well it's no secret why the
Redstone test keep failing it's fine for
suborbital flight but it can't handle
the weight of the capsule and push it
into space God I don't know what you're
saying half this movie but it is so cool
it makes you so fine you figured all
that out with this well what's there
tells the story if you read between the
lines distance from launch to orbit we
know Redstone Mass we know Mercury
capsule weight and the speeds of you did
the math yes sir IBM couldn't do it no
no IBM could not do it and how do you
know about the atlas rocket that Dad is
not here like he said it's classified I
held it up to the light well there it
is oh yeah are you a spy Catherine am I
what I said are you a Russian spy I'm
not
Russian she's not
russing just just to confirm she's a
white lady you can trust her
this interrogation is over figures out
something amazing and the first thing
she become suspect it's how it goes
sadly I mean it's really an ultimate
tense time for everyone here you know
and then to be a black woman involved in
the middle of a very tense place like
this with so much at stake yeah the
middle of achieving major historical
feat yes that's what I'm talking about
ER NASA doesn't commission females for
the engineer training program that
position is available to any qualified
act right except you don't have the
educational requirements I have a
bachelor's degree in mathematics and
physical science is the same as most
Engineers that's right damn you're
genius we have a chance to get ahead
they move a Finish Line I just follow
the rules around here and I expect
everyone who works for me to follow them
as well and I love the rules y all
should be thankful you have jobs at all
what was that saying y'all should be
thankful you have jobs at all no like
the like a weird edit or weird cut no
that was the streamer oh oops we didn't
call attention to
it oh that was a weird editing
Choice won't any trouble in here oh I'm
not here for any trouble man what are
you here
for to mind my own damn business a book
you have books in the color
section prevent them from literature
why I'm so
mad you took that book mom son I pay
tax and taxes pay for everything in that
Library can't take something already a
paper that's why I steal from the
library for Tran is a new and exciting
language used by programmers to
communicate with computer it is exciting
as it is the wave of the future this
book is not as interesting as I hoped it
would
be I thought I grabbed a
fantasy
[Applause]
it's just crazy that like this is a PG
version of it you know and it wasn't
that long like there's still there's
still so many horrible places to be
right now and racism still so real but
like this being the
norm everywhere not that long ago
there's still Sundown towns which is
[Music]
insane come on you know you want
to great I simply misspoke the other day
Mrs go I've been away for a long time
and imagine I'm just out of practice I
went to a woman's rights
class I attended the first
seminar Tau by a woman barely paid
attention you haven't said you're sorry
Yet right of course look at this weird
swaying happening they're just like
barely
move I'm sorry C underestimating you and
any other woman like you though I don't
imagine there's many M that's a really
good way to finish that line off I've
changed my perspective is enhanced but
you are still very unique in my eyes oh
so so well done Yuri Garin has become
the first man in space Gagarin completed
one full orbit around the damn it Cosa
Yori gagarin's 3ka capsule into orbit
re-entering Russian airspace at 755 UTC
you know racism whatever this is what
made America
embarrassing imagine being the first man
in space be horrifying oh my God no
one's ever been this high
before I've been asking myself all the
way over here which is how in the hell
do we find oursel in second place in a
two-man race why do we suck I refuse to
believe that the Russians are smarter
than us or that they have more
technology or that they care more is it
possible that it actually means more to
them we're in the fight of Our Lives
people I just saw seven faces who aren't
sure that we can get there wow there's
only two things you need to know going
forward one is staying here working late
that's going to be a fact of life and
two don't expect your paychecks to
reflect the extra time it's going to
take to catch up and pass those bastards
what a bold statement I suggest you call
your wives on how it's going to be I'll
start with mine working
late does anyone quit who will quit from
this I just want to be a part of it
there too much pressure I got to go I I
want to be a part of it man I wouldn't
want to be a part of such a historical
moment trying to make history
[Music]
here fascinating simulation
process end of the day damn oh
aggressive there hey we we're looking
good where to go
IBM you don't want to leave that behind
which one of you want wants to go
first he's always playing people that
like to
fly this is like his third movie this is
typ
C the guy who gets in a in a in a aerial
[Music]
vehical some sort of craft yeah Top Gun
that one with Jonathan Maes and this one
the computer uses it as its high-speed
storage unit and information holding
device you have a brain that I can work
with oh that's from the wrong spot I
really like the way they're they're
written like our three three female
leads like there's nothing about it that
sounds like preachy at all about them
they are like they have real personality
and they they're also really intelligent
you know yeah I know it feels it feels
very authentic where is
she she is always leaving Having
Fun get this girl a bathroom man she
should have she she should have
addressed it she
should oh her hair got all messed up too
damn where the hell have you been now
where the hell do you go every day
a to the bathroom sir for 40 minutes a
day what are you doing now we're T minus
Z here I put a lot of faith in you oh
jeez there's no bathroom for me here
what do you mean there's no bathroom for
you here there is no bathroom there are
no colored bathrooms in this building or
any building outside the west camp a I
have half a mile Buck to just to relieve
myself and I can't use one of the handy
bikes picture that Mr Harrison oh you
feel embarrassed now don't you lady
skirt below my knees my heels and a
simple String of Pearls well I don't own
pearls Lord knows you don't pay colors
enough to afford pearls Jesus and I work
like a
dog living off a coffee from a pot none
of you want to
touch
wow excuse me if I have to go to the
restroom a few times a day makes feel
pretty embarrassed now man and she's
treated like
garbage he defeated racism no now she
can't have any
coffee oh my God he's doing it he's wh
saving us that's what I'm talking
about I mean in this you kind of need a
whs saer in this position you know
yeah
[Music]
there you have it not going to listen to
No More white restrooms just plain old
toilets go wherever you damn will please
God damn preferably closer your desk men
and women share the same bathrooms now
something tell me that didn't actually
happen that's the only thing I believe
that
[Laughter]
happened he's like all right women are
equal women are equal women are equal
equal and blacks woman and
blacks heard you was fighting the fluig
you could use some soup hot meal for the
girls okay ladies let's say gr uhoh she
getting sick
sick o might as well be married now it's
a historic day here at Cape canaval and
here's what we can expect Alan Shepard
and freedom 7 will be launched into
space at an altitude of about 116 mph
what's taking them so long to get to
space man Russians did it a while ago
God you lazy Americans get it together
Freedom we're going to have to bleed off
some of the pressure inside the liquid
oxygen tank that should some
D I was like CGI that's good
[Laughter]
CG we have
ignition and we have Li it's cool
they're inter spcy with real footage
yeah come on I don't know if that's real
footage sure looks real minutes after
the
hour definitely real yeah they really
got that shot Y is okay Switching manual
R woo we did it we're catching up the
eyes of the world now look into space to
the moon and to the planets Beyond and
we have vowed that we shall not see it
governed by a hostile oh no but by a b
it's a lot harder it inter splices than
it looks wow because there is new
knowledge totally real real footage
suppose we should all thank President
Kennedy for the continued job
security that's
right uh Gus gom's up next another
suborbital flight with a redstone I
sucker for
snaps before we strap Glenn to the atlas
pray we can bring him back down yes and
I imagine he'd like us to have the math
worked out beforehand work gentlemen wow
she's the only one in color in that
whole room oh she must feel special the
colored girl in color little spoton
[Laughter]
movie you know what I like about this H
you know how normally like a movie will
have like the
relegated female love interest that's
what Mersa Ali is he's the love interest
he is the lest look at him I think it's
high time I kissed you C figured you
attracted to me same as out of you he's
got the greatest voice I swear when You'
have told me to get going a long time
ago man is
smooth I'm going to kiss you
now haven't kissed a man in a long time
almost forgot how to a let me remind
you yeah you want do it
again damn you still got the flu
baby arrested four white men accused of
throwing a fire bomb into a freedom
rider bus that is a tragic event it is a
struggle to save the soul of America
Mary it's just crazy they I like that
they're putting the backdrop of what's
going on in the in in America when it
comes to black people meanwhile you got
these black women who are doing
incredible things that sh help shape a
big part of our history yeah it's really
and they been yeah undervalued even in
today's standards cuz most people don't
know about them Hampton High School is a
white School Mrs Jackson yes your honor
I'm aware of that what would warrant a
colored woman attending a white school
May I approach your binge
sir
cff you of all people should understand
understand The Importance of Being first
how's that Mrs Jackson well you were the
first in your family to serve in the
armed forces US Navy damn I bet most
people don't know this and the first
state judge to be recommissioned by
three consecutive Governors she did her
research no negro woman in the state of
Virginia has ever attended an all white
high school and before Alan Shepard sat
on top of a rocket no other American had
ever touch space and now he will forever
be remembered as the US Navy man from
New Hampshire the first first to touch
the St I mainly think about Neil
Armstrong I plan on being an engineer at
Nasa but I can't do that without taking
them classes at that allwhite high
school and I can't change the color of
my skin so I have no choice but to be
the first which I can't do without you
sir hell yeah that's break that that's
cool out of all the cases you going to
hear today which one is going to matter
100 years from now which one is going to
make you the first you trying to make
history or what only the night classes
jez
oh damn oh [__] she slapped her name on
there mhm I'd like to get a jump on John
Glenn's trajectory do you have any idea
what you're asking an orbital launch
with an atlas rocket is going to take
time is there a problem I was wondering
uhhuh well I've been wondering my whole
life so you just spit it
out I would like to get a jump on John
Glenn's trajectory it's like shooting a
saw off shotgun from 1,000 ft and
getting that one BB through a hole so
tiny you can't even see it I'm an
excellent shot how grome numbers been
they've been spot on give Glenn's orbit
ago why does everyone everyone just
doubts her every time but she keeps
proving them wrong how many times you
got to prove herself before you trust
this woman damn computers don't author
reports guyy such a prick I bet he's a
Russian spy loud and
clear okay it's a nice ride up to now
Roger Liberty L 7 this is H approaching
ready to hook on over I read you loud
and clear over space was cool at first
but it's kind of boring out
there there nothing to do out there lack
of stimulation I got to
say floating gets old after a while
unfortunately the Liberty Bell 7 capsule
is lost no gravity's a little underrated
overrated capsu was
lost yeah you shouldn't have made any
jokes
Aaron
very
insensitive we have to know what's out
there Senator we have to touch the Stars
if only to ensure our own Survival and
only a man can do that we'll get John
Glenn home safely because we have to
because he has to tell us what he saw
and that's the only
reason Atlas rocket goes up delivers the
capsule into an elliptical orbit Earth's
gravity keeps pulling at it but is going
so fast it keeps missing the Earth
getting it back down that's the math we
don't
know I figure it out so the capsule will
spin around the Earth forever because
there's nothing to slow it down slowing
it down at precisely the right moment by
precisely the right amount that's the
task yes
Katherine to move from an elliptical
orbit to parabolic no this point it's a
pin head we bring him in too soon he
burns up on re-entry we bring him in too
late he's pushed out of Earth's gravity
and any changes to mass weight speed
time and we start our calculations this
would be very precise yeah thought it
was
easy get over there he's just get a
giant
magnet Pentagon briefing should
illuminate where the Navy needs the
recovery zone then we work backwards
from there and the rest is on us so
let's get to work I just love how it's
like a mission priority it's not some
hey would be great to figure out how to
get to space like this is life or death
leave it's space everything's right this
well we can't keep up I need those
changes as they occur as you said it's a
pin Catherine that's the job when you
asked for this assignment so just
calculate with what you have or we'll
find someone who can oh my God you will
not be able to you guys just value this
woman
please that a
girl hey what the hell are you doing you
can't be in here she fixed the machine
Dorothy B sir well this is a very
delicate piece of equipment I'm sorry
sir I'm just trying to be helpful she
fixed it we've got numbers what kind of
numbers she just wants to be a
supervisor she deserves it what's your
name again Dorth Von Dorth Von she keeps
the job they need someone like her keep
that job get that raise oh this is all
mood we're altering the window on the
capsule when did this happen 6 minutes
ago the math is changing start over if I
could attend the briefings I could stay
we have been through this it is not
possible there is no protocol for is
there a problem look Catherine in
the come on CER use white safe
Costner there's a big cost to not
letting her in there your cost her
[Laughter]
opportunity keep slapping your goddamn
name on her Mr Harrison I would like to
attend today's briefing why is that well
sir the data changes so fast the capsule
changes the weight and the landing zones
are all changing every day she needs to
be in there Coronel Glenn launches in a
few weeks we don't have the man figured
out yet why is it she can't attend cuz
she doesn't have clearance Al I cannot
do my work effectively it's cuz she's a
negro owl Pentagon briefings are not for
civilians it requires the highest
clearance I feel like I'm the best
person to present my calculations no I
am not and she is a woman there is no
protocol for a woman I get that part
Paul I'm a good man
Kevin CER plays good
people who makes the rules you sir you
are the boss you just have to act like
one sir man this guy I feel like this
guy's going to S is he like the villain
of the
movie this's going to sabotage
everything he also has a hidden figure
it's cuz it's really tiny can't
even that's clever find
it her work is pertinent to today's
proceedings come on
rator so awkward with all due respect
our capsules being altered daily we're
orbiting the Earth at what speed
now she can answer
17544 mph that's what I'm talking about
at the time the rocket delivers the
capsule into low space orbit there it is
so we have the vehicle speed the launch
window and for arguments sake The
Landing zone is the Bahamas should be
enough to figure the go no go yeah in
theory sir we need to be past Theory at
this point we'll be able to it's just a
theory a space Theory a space
Theory Catherine have a go at it do your
thing Catherine do your thing Catherine
I allow you use the white
chock now if I was one of these B
background players I'd be overdoing
it be
like black
woman in the room if we assume that's
the
Bahamas at
17,5 44
milph entry yeah yeah screw you IBM of
4656 I think IBM's actually been very
helpful for us I should take this they
still use it do you know do they I don't
know chat gbt
now
32t distance would be 20 million look
got to go to work man I wonder what her
preparation process was for this movie
that's a good
question
mil he's like I've never seen her
actually do this this is crazy my first
time this is crazy that's awesome Shin Z
at 5 0 66 7° North yep 33° West B you
feel like a real ass now Jim person like
get
out you don't have
clearance you're a woman that of course
is assuming the capsule hits the
re-entry point exactly how do we ensure
that he's still so shocked by what he
just
witnessed we're working on it
Catherine gentlemen I'd like to sleep
with
her
that was the hottest thing I've ever
seen programmers folks to feed the cars
we get them for crying out loud okay
you're the IBM man right yes sir we pull
out the sky if you have to let's get
ahead of this thing I'm not paying you
where's that black girl get the black
girl back out here K going to be like
are all the black girls running
everything around
here it's like they've had to do all
this the Shadows that are coming to the
light temporarily yes we need the abbm
for Glenn's launch the lead engineer
says you're good with the cards pring
they're the hidden
figures is that what the movie's title
was what about after now after Glenn's
launch NASA's dissolving the Computing
group really I'm not accepting re unless
I bring my ladies with there you go
there you go we're going to need a lot
of manpower to program that Beast I
can't do it alone oh my God so cool and
they know they need her so no matter
they need her so bad like oh wait to
elevate we've been reassigned oh God I
am nothing like her I would abandon
everyone here at this channel for
greater
success sorry
[Music]
ladies holy [__] this all a true story I
I got to look up what's true what is
that's that is wild that that's so
amazing
that is so cool I got to look this up I
got to let's pause the
movie right
now look at her math in way saying
things I'll never
understand find a genius among those
Geniuses pull us all up we all get to
the peak together or we don't get there
at all well good night Sir you're fired
Paul I don't know what time I'm coming
home you got something to say thought
you might need to you can refill with
any weight LED man these two would have
such beautiful children two gorgeous
people you're going to make a fine
engineer you think so yes a and nobody
there standing away a Mary Jackson's
dreams a don't make me late you w't be
late I'm make you you w be late it's
nice to see a movie like his men
supporting like the men supporting women
and uh supportive black and and and you
got these two male leading actors sure
relegated to the
romance you just don't see that that
often I'm Mary Jackson I'm enrolled man
maybe you right this is all high
schoolers ER yeah something in the water
back then curriculum is not designed for
teaching a woman well I imagine it's the
same as teaching a man I don't see a
colored section should I just take any
seed thank you that's cool take the
[Music]
front okay everyone look
schooler is when the capsule moves from
an elliptical orbit to a parabolic orbit
there's no mathematical formula for that
calculate launch and Landing but without
this conversion the capsule stays in
orbit we can't bring it back home right
right right I I think I know what you're
saying maybe we've been thinking about
this all wrong oh yeah maybe yeah yeah
definitely I'm right there in the room
with you guys that's how I keep my
job uhhuh
yeahhuh something that looks at the
problem new Al and not theoretically
that's a good point Oiler method Oiler
method yes mutter
mutter that's ancient Ponder Ponder
Ponder Ponder what a radical way of
thinking that's it let's type it up are
you going to let her put her name on it
you're going to give her the credit it's
going to have that moment be like hey it
doesn't say by
Catherine yeah see yeah oh he's going to
he's going to have his moment where he
says it do it man do it we need
redemption or else I'm not going to
watch big Bank Theory
anymore I hear the IBM's up to full
capacity you certainly have a knack for
it my father taught me a thing or two
about mechanics I have a few girls in
the East group that have an interest in
learning more about it that's not my
decision ma'am that would be the
supervisor yes that's true are you going
to offer it to her in the bathroom you
know Dorothy despite what you may think
I have nothing against y'all I know you
probably believe
that damn she just knows how to Octavia
Fester knows how to drop lines like that
she's so good you don't know what she
going to say but something clever's
about to come
out some bar about to drop some truth
truth bombs in here you probably believe
that but wait is it my birthday no
mama you all look so pretty it's Daddy's
deathiversary mama what's going on good
evening Catherine what's happening okay
well I'm not going to do this all
night oh Mother of
Mercy that's for me oh is he doing this
in front of the whole family no a no
it's okay Mama he's a good man I know
what I know I just I just can't help you
hasn't even asked you
yet yo no my mother's ring
beautiful she and my father were married
for for 52
years that girl's good numbers I said
Mom I'm at the woman I want to marry
what' she say she said she must be
something Jimmy really something then
what' you say I said no she more than
something she's everything oh hell yeah
this guy's good too man I plan on on
this being more romantic I'll make that
up to you real soon this is great what
are you talking about but I know
marrying you includes man and your girls
as
well that is so sweet I
do I ask you again hurry up
a that is so sweet that can't be truth
no no man's the
smart to do it for the whole family like
that oh that's great it's like proposing
me like will you accept me as your St
father that's great in fact our IBM is
turning out numbers in fractions of the
time any human can present company
included that's good then they haven't
even like been able to really talk with
each other huh the girls no it's been a
minute since we've seen them all
together thing is the cape's now
insisting on doing all the backups down
there on side so we won't be running
backups here and truth be told we can't
keep up with that IBM anyhow long story
short we no longer need a computer in
this
department wow she got you guys this far
and she going to throw her away like
trash we heard you got engaged yes huh
it's thoughtful of
you a Mr Harrison's idea really although
I suspect his wife did the picking up
can't imagine he has an eye for anything
but numbers now you have a great wi did
good work around here Catherine white
people approve crazy how there's like a
sense of irony about it you know cuz she
helped get the IBM thing working putting
her out of a job and a little
Fuller what you look good here we go
again Octavia advancing herself kind of
screwed over her
friend that's what I
[Laughter]
[Music]
was Paul something's off here these
Landing coordinates don't match
yesterday's that's why you can't trust
chat
gbt even though it comes up with
everything I say on camera
even that was scripted by Chad
gbt I'm just reading a prompt right
now the IBM's been spot on up to this
point we'll run it again see what it
comes up with when I fly I fly the
machine right now seems like this
machine's flying me let's get the girl
to check the numbers wow really did that
really happen you mean Catherine yes sir
the smart one I mean if she says they're
good I'm ready to go all right we'll get
into it Roger did that call really
happen oh
Wonder yeah go find Catherine goo she
needs to verify Glenn's go no go we're
staying on the ground she had wedding
right now did she already get married
she had a wedding and there was a time
Tri or is she I have to imagine for
movie purposes they're going to have it
happen at her wedding we need you like
as she's about to say her V we didn't
see the wedding
no I feel like this is happening
simultaneously I love how he's having to
do the running too now looking for
Catherine Goble it's Catherine Johnson
now they need you to okay mind I wish
would have saw the wedding that's all
gather John Glenn is ready to board the
Friendship s but today we remain truly
optimistic and it's a go day in all
regards God I got to become a
billionaire so I can go to
space what would you do in space with
your billions take a
dump watch it spin in the
air I
[Laughter]
would after years of waiting and months
of delay Colonel Glenn is finally ready
for that space
flight that's it were the calculations
wrong what the devil are you doing are
you taking a
[Music]
break they're going to run half a
mile
they just shut her out cner bring her in
tear down that that door they had her
run all the way there and then they just
shut her out that's crazy Cosner's going
to open it though what
they
[Laughter]
cner come
on come on I'm saving you come
on did that really happen
I doubt it what happened
movie I I I would love to see I got to
find out I got to find out we can
confirm the go no go point for re-entry
is is in his contract has like I have to
wipe save a minimum of three times hey
man he's doing it let him do his
thing he danced with Wolves now he saves
black
people a true American hero the launch
window is a go The Landing coordinates
match that is very good news Al it's a a
little hard to trust some you can't look
in the eyes Catherine did manage to
calculate a few decimal points further
than that honk of metal and we are
watching this on Disney plus right
now who would Echo the same sentiment as
CH
GL
awesome get a little bumpy along here
you are in Max
Q whoa wow John Glen reports everything
looks good you go Glenn how what's his
name Howard John Glen pow Glen
po here we go Glen
pal thank you cap pil it away all 10 and
a half hours to go if we make seven
round trips honestly I feel like you get
over space really fast you're bored all
right 10 hours I'm I'm good I don't
think I need to do it again s everything
I need to see new assignment came down
the PK always changing around here it's
hard to keep
up what they're going to need a
permanent team to feed that IBM how big
of a team 30 to start thank you for the
information Mrs Mitchell you're quite
welcome Mrs B now do you think do you
still think I'm racist do do you like me
now have I been
redeemed I like these cheesy overcome
races I really do I think I like them
all I don't hate colors my dog's
black the heat shield may have come
loose seven will you confirm the landing
bag is in the off position affirmative
Capcom now she's going to have to do
something exclusive that IBM cannot
solve NASA is confirming there is some
sort of malfunction with the capsule's
heat shield and if may not stay in place
Jesus the Retro package straps might
might hold it in place it will hold it
until he reaches the go no go point it
will work he has to override the 05g you
should get your engineer in here the
Retro package not I repeat not be
jettison me that you will have to
override the 05g switch is there a
reason for this over do we telling the
truth I don't want to freak him
out he's not a
professional you can't handle the
pressure not at this time
s Roger that command without a heat
shield there is no way that Colonel
Glenn can get back through the Earth's
atmosphere I don't know if I've seen a
movie that actually captures this where
you just see like the civilians all
watching and looking up at the sky
usually like cut to people like watching
the television or listening to news but
just like oh man there's a guy up there
right now you know like how
weird I wonder if people actually did
this though I oh I bet yeah like
actually like gather like looking up at
the sky and [__] when this was happening
yeah man they're all listening to this
is a Monumental
moment you're going out he's crossing
the communication blackout Zone there's
a real Fireball outside it's getting a
little hot in
here no there's
[Music]
not it's getting hot in here friendship
seven do you copy
over again friendship 7 do you copy
over
boom that's [__] up friendship 7 do
you copy
over let clear
Capcom Roger that how are you doing I
feel like my sk's on fire but I'm
good engaging
shoots beautiful shoot your go no go is
good Landing coordinates are spot on S
I've always wanted to swim in the
Bahamas over like these scenes are so
prevalent in movies and imagine just
like it has the emotional resolution or
something like this but like something
goes horribly wrong at the end John
Glenn has splashed down safely and is
being recovered by the USS Noah hell
yeah man that's what I'm talking about
yeah you think we can get to the mo
we're already there sir post credit
scene Catherine will
return hat figures
to John Glenn successful committed three
of a scheduled seven orbit flight yeah
well done John it was all
you friendship S turn the tight Space
Race play NASA the moon in 1969 that's
what I'm talking about America
yeah Mary Jackson Nas is an America's
first female African-American
aeronautical engineer 199 she was
appointed Lang Le woman program manager
where she fought to advance woman of all
colors hell yeah hell yeah
supervisor show you how things kst death
is not racist in real
[Laughter]
life first African-American supervisor
damn as a for specialist on the front
tier of electronic Computing she was
regard as one of the most Brilliant
Minds in NASA oh awesome what a what a
step up that's
amazing oh yeah put your name on that
paper put your name on that document
Catherine you earned
it a what you getting her the coffee
white Redemption we've come a long
way Catherine was fired shortly
thereat wow we're dark have to perform
calculations for the Apollo to the moon
and space shuttle that's what I'm
talking about NASA dedicated the
Katherine G Johnson computational
Building honor for groundbreaking work
in space travel that's awesome man these
three women are incredible
9797 the presidential medal of freedom
and celebrate 56th anniversary of Jim
Johnson awesome amazing I'm sure
everything was just great for her you
know whole journey I'm sure we didn't
leave anything out no more racism after
this wow oh it's not real her wow she
looks just like
her cool exactly like
[Music]
her damn kind of looks like Tessa
Thompson actually I can see that
yeah whoa jackon Jackson look at them
ladies wow ladies that's
beautiful that's awesome hidden figures
wow indeed damn I'd watch a I'd watch a
documentary about them oh yeah in my own
time don't ask us to
react Katherine will return all
right I must I must I mean I want to see
the photos but must prepare for for
facts
checking must learn if what's true and
what isn't true must download
information on factual accuracy must
learn but did Kevin Cosner actually tear
the sign
down did he open that door for
her hey bed on a book or
something it's based on real life damn
look at the people work done oh wow look
at
that oh cool
wow
a oh wow that's
amazing
man it would have been great to meet one
of them
story I would have shaken their head and
been like I know exactly what it feels
like to be
you I I can I have very similar
experience I completely identify with
everything you've been through
everything before and during my God look
it's mersel holy hey man not like a
black man is light-skinned very
lightskinned Glenn
Powell it look like an Asian guy are you
sure thought it was an Asian
guy Glen palcon looks like an Asian guy
no Le's guy
oh snap Diggity yeah yeah thanks to
everyone who worked on this movie thank
you to America's number one meal kid
hellofresh for partnering with us it's
always great to partner with people
whose Services you actually use because
it's someone like me who's always
juggling a pack schedule between filming
and editing finding time for health
eating can be a challenge that's where
hellofresh has been a game changer for
my life with hellofresh I get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and delicious
recipes delivered right to my doorstep
so I don't have to step outside it's
revolutionized my home cooking
experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable keyw I
recently tried their delicious barbecue
pineapple flat RADS and their zucchini
pomodora Panet bake both were mouth
wateringly delicious and fit perfectly
with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian sounds fancy and ask my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it in the fuo chicken faito
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time too not having a wait in
line at a grocery store even self
checkouts on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portion right to your door
is priceless especially with her quick
and easy meals like 15-minute recipes
spending less time in the kitchen and
more time doing what I love which is
filming and editing so here's the deal
if you want a great way to support the
channel and also support you know having
a new lifestyle healthy affordable
lifestyle in the year 2024 go to
hellofresh.com reject free and use code
rejects free for free breakfast for life
you heard that right one breakfast item
per box while the subscription is active
free breakfast for life for
hellofresh.com reject free use promo
code reject free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy
and let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get
real for a moment running this channel
is incredible managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for
the channel and my personal life can be
overwhelming that's where rocket money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me
even before I ever partnered up with
them like I said I've been very
fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a
win-win for a while but it can be a
win-win for you too cuz there's a reason
I use them rocket money is a personal
finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I
was overspending stuff I don't use that
I kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
the heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials I
signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free Tri was done
making it super easy to cancel the ones
you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket
telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you
forgot about because rocket money is a
huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiate some of my bills down
to like 20% so if you're ready to take
control of your finances and there's no
better time than now because it is the
beginning of the year check out rocket
money and see how much you could be
saving stop wasting money on things you
do not use so to help support the
channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money.com rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident
they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank
account will thank you all right all
film kicks off in 1961 and takes place
over the following two years yeah like a
couple years but in reality Mary Jackson
became the first black female engineer
in s 58 in Dorothy vom history of
becoming a supervisor more than a decade
early in 1949 oh they need some drama
they still they still made that impact
in history they still made their Mark by
earlier getting these positions
graduations the three women's closeness
I was really wondering about this CU
they barely together in the film that
hurts it hurts that they weren't close
they barely well let's find out let's
find out all right all right Mary
Katherine Dorothy didn't actually cross
paths as much as in the film they seem
like they were best buds right and they
definitely weren't close friends who
attended events for family Milestones
this narrative change put the woman
together a variety of scenarios where
they actually went have worked together
frequently emphasizing their closest in
the film let them Express themselves to
other women who are in a similar
situations to themselves but it's also
not really true yeah you see I had just
a very cuz none of their stories really
related to each other cuz I was like
what a coincidence that the three of
them would be best friends and and go to
work together and then also make these
like massive achievements and individual
spots and their personal like what a
crazy these are the coolest friends I've
ever seen I mean still a massively
impressive what they've done but once I
realize like they're not really sharing
that many scenes together and it's
really mainly Catherine story I started
questioning the validity of how close
they were all right police
incident uh yeah that carpool scene's
probably made up because they didn't
actually hang out with each other yeah
all right oh okay hold on SEC okay
Katherine me told women aren't allowed
in briefings I
right
okay uh
okay oh that's actually pretty accurate
of how she like got in to the briefings
that's cool that's
awesome oh Kevin Ker's character all
right let's see he plays he's not a real
guy Harrison Harrison is not her
real movies director wasn't able to
secure the r to portray the real person
who wanted to so create a character who
is a composite of three different NASA
directors oh my God car similarly Jim
Parson wasn't real which is for the best
ining his racist and sexist attitudes
find the woman that cir n played Vivien
Mitchell is also a fictional creation
holy [__] our three main whes ain't even
real whes wow cuz the real white people
were so bad they couldn't be on
screen C was like I want to be the super
white yeah let them be subtly racist or
not so subtle getting rid of the SEC
gated toilet wrong and one of the most
satisfying moments of the movie Kevin
C's character dramatically smashes the
sign for the color lady's bathroom there
are a few problems with the scene one
Coster did not exist second segregation
ended at Langley in 1958 oh wow some
critics argue that this created an
unnecessary white savior moment hey
there's always room for a white savior
moment what else do they have in a movie
like this the movie screenwriter and
director ctor Theodore melie countered
that there needs to be white people who
do the right thing there needs to be
black people who do the right thing and
someone does the right thing and so who
cares who does the right thing as long
as the right thing is achieved before we
read the rest the mie are you white or
black I must find out because you know
it's a fair point he's a white guy he's
white he did a good job though look good
it's a good it was it was a so like your
movie Man movie it was a good movie
great looking
wife Kimberly Quinn awesome I I don't
know who you you people are all right um
I like the movie guys all right
Katherine Johnson Computing John Glenn's
trajectory that is correct hell yeah
when the first American doo in the movie
we see Katherine working on Glen chory
which is totally accurate is that uh
when IBM computers seem to be giving
them inconsistent numbers Glen Glenn
really did ask for johnon civility to
check out the figures for him and that
he was willing to fly that day if she
confirm them because hidden figures is a
double meaning Ern what y he talking
about the figures but also they're the
figures in history that have oh my god
get it margar Le sh the author of the
book H and figure she is based on a book
dude okay uh so the Astron became a hero
looked to the black woman in this still
segregated South at the time as one of
the key parts of making sure his mission
would be a success is what I'm talking
about that is a
real it's not really a savior moment
it's actually the black one who saved
but it makes him look
great running half a mile they used the
bathroom Okay dramatic for dramatic
effect uh she had half a mile to another
building in order to use the colored
bathroom in fact Mary Jackson Who
encountered the problem Mary it was Mary
Jackson Who encountered this problem not
Johnson both had start Lang before the
NAC okay all right just Swit it around
yeah cther Catherine's experience a
workplace racism shocker um is wrong
Katherine takes a stand against the
segregation in NASA the real Katherine
has stated that racism didn't affect her
much in the birth place everyone was
really nice they brought her gifts every
day when she spoke to w H TV she said I
didn't feel the segregation NASA because
everyone was there doing research
actually is a shocker sarcasm at first
you had a mission and you worked on it
it was important to you to do your job
and play bridge at lunch I didn't feel
any segregation I knew it was there but
I didn't feel it perhaps to reflect prac
I mean you got to have the drama man
here's the thing I feel like cuz after
seeing what they actually look like I'm
going to say that like there's a little
colorism at play here she's a very like
fair skinned light-skinned black woman
which I feel like if she was a darker
skinned black woman she would have
gotten more harsher treatment you think
so definitely let's look her
up Catherine Langley especially back
then yeah what's her last name ly
lingford it wasn't Johnson is it Johnson
she got married came Johnson but what
was she known as no Langley is the place
of is yeah I think you're right God damn
it you might be right Katherine
Johnson yeah it's easy to remember not
bad two and a half hours in PID for we
got s more
minutes we're right here we need a look
at the colored photo we need a colored
photo of the black woman that's not her
is that her yeah it's her she's like
she's like white
passing I mean as a super old lady maybe
she got that way as she got
older I don't know maybe wife
why are all the younger photos in black
and white what's up with that I
can't I don't know man I mean she at
some photos she she looks like
definitely black where I'm not saying
she doesn't look black I'm just saying
because she's lighter skinned that
colorism is at play cuz they're like you
look closer to us in tone okay we can be
was easier to accept but yeah she was
like like Daniel kala black they'd be
like oh I don't trust these colored
yeah that's fair I don't know I mean no
I do
know plays it plays oh yeah that's
fair uh segregation is very real in the
street
uhuh uhuh okay all right wow well you
kind of pick up on it as the movie goes
that some of this is a little Hokey
Pokey that's why it feels very Hollywood
that's why I just started making jokes
because I was like you can just tell
that some of this just is like you know
that has that like H but I can't lie to
you guys I enjoy it I enjoy that kind of
[__] for some reason even when I'm
watching it going like come on or yeah a
white savior movie I I love them I eat
them up I eat your white savior I I
really do enjoy them and um I think
there's just enough actual really good
things in here that really work for me I
think it's a touching story it still
effectively gets the point across um the
like the the important part about and
like the the important part about it
that I think they got right is uh the
mark that they were able to make and
like they really did become in they
really did come into the positions that
they came into as the first
African-American women to do so you know
and a lot of especially for someone like
Katherine Johnson did some very
extremely pivotal important stuff and
and I think con conveying that is
important even if you have to like do
some narrative bullshitting to get it
done you know I still think they got
that point across and uh it it got me
curious to like want to look up with I
was like I just got to know I got to
find out so you learn a little bit more
about the truth behind it and it's a
story that I won't ult I will ultimately
never forget and I my immediate reaction
was like oh I'd love to see like a
documentary about them uh like to really
learn the truth so I think for those
purposes alone it's good it's it's a
touching story it's another story about
you know like don't be racist because
you never know like they might be you
might be able to get some good gains
from them
right it's the lesson that be learned
yeah don't be racist don't be a freaking
prick don't be RAC you might be able to
you might be able to benefit off of
their knowledge and
labor and their
labor great choice of wordss
same oh
God I hey man look I'm not despite what
you think I have nothing against any
people my dog's
black I vote for my dog
twice that's funny that's my dog right
there oh man okay I mean I also liked
the movie I will say
that part of me is
like I I felt the Holiness of the movie
too and it it does sadden me a little
bit seeing some of these stuff some of
the things that we looked up are uh
actually inaccurate but you kind of
sense that as you're watching as well
well let me ask let let me put it to you
like this then before we looked up this
stuff yeah because I can easily look at
this stuff but still know exactly how I
feel about the movie
um does any of before we looked it up
what was your feelings before we looked
it up I thought that 10 out of 10
Masterpiece best black movie of the year
no I think before I looked it up or we
looked it up I thought it was
entertaining I think that
you know I like the parallels between
what the black experience was at the
time versus what they were experiencing
within their workplace it wasn't to the
severity of what they knew on the
outside but still it was present and I
just think that watching it uh yeah made
me really grateful and it showed the
strength of what it was like to be not
only black not only a woman but both of
those things within that workplace and
God knows being black and a woman is
hard in America so being black and a
woman in the 60s was even tougher and
the amount of West Virginia my God and
West Virginia yeah and the strength you
got to have on top of being a mother so
you got to like feed your kids and go to
work and deal with the workplace drama
of it and I think the the part that like
really hit me was the fact that you know
before we look this up the the
fictionalized version of Katherine had
to go half a mile to use the bathroom
and then she has to go home to her kids
and tuck them into bed at night I was
like oh man like
to to her kids that she's a Superhero
you know she's like she's doing it she's
Paving away for these children and they
have no idea the kind of stuff she has
to deal with at work maybe they have
some sement of understanding because she
is you know a black woman in the world
and like these kids have to experience
that because of where they live and the
time they're living in but the fact that
she's experiencing that as well and then
she has to go and put on a brave face
for them was just really uh really
inspiring ing you know
and I I liked all the stuff that we got
to experience
I the reason why I said earlier because
like you you know that it's two years
but I think a lot because the stuff with
mersi and her was like it was in smaller
bits if that whole romance aspect felt a
little fast for me I was like they M and
then he's coming to dinner and then
they're getting married I was like oh
damn okay this is like boom boom boom
they had good chemistry
don't get me wrong but I just feel like
I would have liked to seen more of that
you know
and yeah I it is a little disheartening
to find out that they weren't actually
really good friends in real life and I
think something I would have liked to
have seen addressed is the fact that um
octavus Spencer's character's
achievement had an adverse effect on
affecting Catherine and we didn't really
touch on that at all during the movie
but you know I don't it's not directly
her fault for going after something that
she wanted to be the supervisor while
she was trying to gain respect within uh
the room yeah of these these crafts she
knew that she that they were going to
figure it out so if she figured it out
she could help bring everyone along with
her yeah yeah so that was like the
purpose of it uh yeah know man I I I
agree with you I I still think because
of the time it takes place in that I I
weird didn't question if that was true
if she had to like go go to the bathroom
um yeah I'm like you just accept it
sounds like a thing that someone would
probably have to endure that a black
woman would probably have to endure in a
workplace like this during this time and
and as much as this is like the PG movie
because it's like a family accessible
version of this story which is why I I
give a lot of it to the pass because it
is and gr like I cannot talk from the
black experience of watching a movie
like this I can not talk from the
African-American experience of it I I'm
watching from that lens of like it's a
PG movie so I know they're going to like
tone down a lot of like what the
day-to-day really felt like during this
time you know so as much as they
dramatize certain aspects to hammer in
like even how in the fact versus fiction
page they were explaining how you know
Katherine didn't even really feel the
racism and that's probably because she I
can
imagine I'm going to make an assumption
here I I don't really like to make an
assumptions I'm going to I would imagine
that when you grow up in a state like
that
being a black woman you probably deal
with all kinds of [__] all the [__]
time that this is probably like so
minimal in comparison that's like yeah
no it's h it's here but I'm not that
affected by it because I've dealt I deal
with so much worse on a day-to-day basis
you know so I can imagine that that that
is probably it so you do need like the
drama for your specific narrative that
you're going to tell because you
otherwise people aren't going to really
if we did the super realistic version
people probably wouldn't show up for the
movie um you know it might not be as
interesting enough you know unless
you're like Christopher Nolan making the
film white saving their black
story well if it was a realistic version
of the film like none of this would
would correlate because all the stuff
happened at different times so I will
judge it as a narrative and as a
narrative I I do think that uh yeah I I
kind of do wish because you start off
with the three women and they do seem
like they really just
Splinter off Splinter off and I wish
there was a bit of a stronger connective
bow to them yeah because I together
again I would kind of forget about uh
octavus Spencer and Janelle Monae yeah
i' forget about M Jan mon alavia Spencer
cuz I felt like her was like the C or D
story of this whole movie exactly there
was yeah was 2 hours and 7 minutes I
feel there was a lot going on for that
amount of time cuz they're like yeah
there's their stories and stories of the
church the stories of what's going on in
with civil rights and then there's her
getting married you know on top of that
or her relationship
and yeah the also the I guess it was
just to establish but I thought the her
being like this young Prodigy in the 20s
up to her adulthood would be more like
relevant yeah because like seeing her
seeing her see the the shapes and
geometry I was like I guess that's just
a starting point like an entry point to
to show how long she's been this smart I
was like yeah I think you know maybe her
being doubted everyone okay everyone in
the black community was super supportive
of these three women being like these uh
these forward smart you know I'm sure
they said the pay wasn't great but still
I I think that I maybe because the PG
movie they don't want any like
additional like layers on top of the
fact that you know they're these black
wom within this uh this world of of NASA
and like being the minority in that part
but also push back from within the
community as well that are complicated
things but yeah and it was nice to see
you know support of black husbands or
black romantic uh people in this as you
were kind of saying in the movie A lot
of the times these movies will you know
like like's got an alcoholic black
husband or boyfriend or something you
know that's something that's something I
will I will say like there wasn't it was
very
Hollywood eyes but it wasn't like the
stereotypical movie in which we see
where it's like you know about like
drums or like the baby mama drama or
like all of this stuff like granted was
is which is obviously real people's
experiences but I liked that it the
light in which uh these women were
painted in in this movie I love that
they had a straight up white saer vot
that makes me so happy like they
completely made that [__] up it's crazy
that dude wasn't even real bro it's
probably like one of the biggest moment
of the
movie that is such a big
moment happen he's three different guys
and right away you were like that
probably didn't happen right away he
said it I'm like yeah it probably didn't
happen he looked it up like this guy
didn't even exist and it's such a big
moment in the
movie insane such a crowning achievement
look what I've
done oh it's so funny wow that cracks me
up that was a great moment though it was
it was good I like that [__] I do I eat
it up eat up eat up the cliches because
well like I think the movie is is very
for a movie that starts off about like
geometry and shapes I what I respect
very much so is the the way this movie
is framed I I think there's the I think
the cinematography in this movie is the
kind of thing that could easily be
overlooked but there's there's a lot of
like wide framing that they do
throughout where I felt like every shot
was actually really composed but it
wasn't done in a way that was to like go
look at me I'm a cool director you know
but it's still shot really well like
every shot is really well composed but
it doesn't feel flashy or self-indulgent
it's a little self-indulgent in the
writing but not so much in the actual
directing they did and even though Kevin
CER was a madeup guy I thought he
actually did a really great job thought
Kevin CER was excellent I I I really
liked him a lot
um still no B no no no boldness on the
just made him like that the only really
nice white guy all n is Kevin
cner all he cares about science space
and equal
rights so funny cuz you're like there's
no way you're the only one the fact
you're the only one makes me go there
must have been other people who were
cool with black people
or you had or it's totally [__] that
you you were the only one who was nice
yeah um as we were watching it I
realized I'm like I don't think Kristen
dun has any other scenes with anybody
else in this movie yeah yeah or to and
that's the other Pitfall of the movie
they go into white Redemption like
racist Redemption character mode with
with some of these people you know and
um like look they can change we all can
change we should accept black view that
quote Oh that was such a terrible quote
from that director but man that cheese I
love the cheese in the moment I really
do I I I can acknowledge it because it
is one of those things where you're like
oh it is the
line it it is the line that uh Octavia
Spencer has the the bar that she drops
of of when kirston dun says I have
nothing against you know y'all and then
she
goes uh I know you believe
that fact and that's kind of this movie
this movie believes that everything it's
doing is great and and that it's it's
well-intentioned it's like they so when
I'm watching this film I'm going well it
it's got heart's in the right place I
think they think their hearts in the
right
place and that's okay I guess look at us
look let's Pat ourselves in the back for
this one guys the end of the day they're
saying don't be
racist that one can't be wrong with that
don't be racist believe in black woman
in science yeah and at theend day did
introduce to a really cool story with
and with great performances from
particularly um what's her name teraji I
don't know Taj P Henson that is her name
I don't know why I gu myself the
bathroom scene or the reveal the when
she's talking to Kevin CER I'm like
that's your Oscar moment that's your
Oscar scene right there that's what I
mean that moment right there I was I got
distracted going this is totally like
Oscar Oscar scene here that's the scene
they play with the Oscars great speech
but
totally totally aware what this scene
I'm looking at is right now like really
well done but I'm also hyper aware that
this is your Oscar bait scene oh yeah oh
something I wanted to see the um if this
was up for an Oscar the costume you're
chargeing for over time we're about to
20 seconds away from Two and a Half
armor we're going to say that it was not
n for an Oscar oh let's want to see if
it's nominated for anything we can find
out yeah let's find out I don't have the
a whole bunch of other stuff to do after
this
year let's find
it all
right osar let's go let's go what were
you were you nominated for
anything what do you look nominated for
three Oscars ah costuming is one of them
I know it I hope
so and Kevin CER was Nom that would be
crazy you can see it happening didn't
Sandra b win for the Blind Side did she
yeah think what you w for I've never
seen it I got to watch it especially now
I'll watch it by myself I don't
[Laughter]
care damn you internet load okay here we
go oh dude it was nominated for best
pitcher was it
really I thought it was good I don't
think it was best picture good OCT oia
Spencer got oh best supporting actress
okay yeah so okay no costume ones I mean
Octavia Spencer's like Oscar darling she
won for the help oh such a white saers
movie still need to watch great movie
though I love that
[Laughter]
movie problematic way more problematic
than this movie really oh yeah when you
look up that [__] freaking um what's her
name Viola Davis like says that like
that was a mistake for her to make that
movie yeah really yeah yo so good at
it what he said she shouldn't have made
it that's crazy something something
along the lines pretty much like
disowning the film oh wow okay now that
makes me want to watch it more and the
writer best adapted screenplay okay
could have SW was nominated for
costuming well well well got nominated
for something so I'm half right dude
dude M Hera won the best actor at the
BET awards are you serious for barely in
the movie showing up and being Pleasant
you just he just nice just a nice black
man that's all he whatever I'm sure
there's an actor more deserving that
year oh it's because it's shared with um
luk cage because he had like a multiple
amount of roles that year I think oh
okay all right all right okay that makes
more sense right is that this movie is
telling me that was my introduction name
Luke Cage oh my God he's one of the best
wies favorite movies greenbook have you
seen that green book's great I love that
movie best wh one of the
[Music]
best it's a buddy movie it's a road trip
buddy movie oh my God but it's he's
fantastic in that movie he is he won the
Oscar as he should have as you should
have and um and and U when when the
director won best picture I don't think
you even think MERS Le oh wow of course
he didn't of course he didn't
white white thanks for getting me here
savior
Savor mov best
one oh God we could have had a more
nuanced uh discussion about it but I
think we I think we did our job we we
were
honest and uh I liked it what would you
give it out of 10 er let's end this I go
to
seven I'm probably there with you yeah
seven what's up Rod Tomatoes that's a
great movie though which one American
fiction thanks for watching a movie I
know I know
my fourth favorite movie in
[Laughter]
2023 damn dude 93% all the out of 50,000
people
wow they they are how many of them are
[Laughter]
white oh man all right let's do a let's
do a whole new
[Laughter]
review oh God that's crazy it's a true
Triumph I'm just going to type in an
important film what if we like the only
ones who like had slight issues with
it I thought it was a good
movie The Wrong lesson white people
learn from White saer
movies yeah no man it's a good movie
yeah I all the all the leads were great
you know it's just the the moving around
of times and and creating a story hey
it's a crowd pleasing good time I had a
fun time Aaron does it feel good movie I
had a fun time feel good movie inspired
all righty guys well what do you think
about hidden figures leave your thoughts
down below be sure to uh should I watch
The Blind
Side should you should watch The Blind
Side watch The Blind Side then talk
about how that movie is problematic
nah dude there's a crowd fer white
savior movies are meant to be crowd fers
they are that's what they all are just
enjoy them and don't think about it they
meant to be they're meant to be like
yeah it's meant to ease your white guilt
it's
okay oh God I think the intention of
white savior movies
too is to inspire white people to not be
racist that's the Genius of them Aon
we're not so bad it's okay is that look
look doesn't it feel good to not be to
not be racist we could be like that like
wow I shouldn't be racist that's
cool it works I think it's a great movie
uh leave your thoughts down below hidden
figures 2 Katherine Ward
turn Maria Hammond Maria it was your
birthday recently so wanted to say happy
birthday to you and for
2024 we got to send you a gift yes we do
what are we realistically going to send
her a puppy
no uh your responsibility we don't want
it we found it on the street take it
please take it is it alive we just
packed it in a UPS box taped
it like fragile here's a bowl of water
hopefully it doesn't fall over spill all
over this thing um oh goodness we could
get her something commemorative we could
name a star after
her that's not a bad gift John you know
I'm saying like I mean of all things to
commemorate your cost more than what she
pays every month for undoubtedly so you
know what we'll have to financial if you
can increase your pledge so we can get
you this St this gift yeah I think you
only have to pay for it once so like you
know you don't subscribe to the star
unfair see what you did you wanted the
start and now you just took advantage of
us made it seem like you forging and now
we got to give you a gift once you fully
paid off your gift
thanks but seriously app we got we got
to get you of it already thinking about
it but no thank you for being such an
amazing human being here's to another 78
more years of minim enjoying not saying
you're 78 I was just throwing out a
random number just to stay alive for at
least that much more time lives
past like 80 on average right yeah it's
like the going rate right now what is
the average person Maria let's make this
really fun for your birthday what is the
average mortality yeah John type it in
what is the average mortality rate what
is the
a average I really don't know
how3 okay so we're getting close
7316 years according to quar
okay the average life expectancy in the
world right now hope I hope you be the
first person what is the oldest person
I've ever lived who's the old actually
70 years for men and 75 for women yeah
okay they got less problems that's why
that's right much more relaxed life what
is the oldest
person how old is the current
oldest person in the
world oh you can beat them all right
Maria they're only 116 years old they
live in Spain their name's also Maria oh
my God holy [__] it was meant to be
Maria you got to be the new dominant
extended life Maria yes if you could
just make it to 118 I think you got a
good amount of distance between the next
runner up so we're going to do whatever
it takes that's what we're going to do
we're going to send you an IV we're
going to get you cry Frozen we're going
to uh send you some vitamins we're going
to get you some uh oh oh that
that baby blood stuff that people are
always freaking out about yeah people
talk about quality of life not quantity
hell with that I don't care how
miserable you get I don't care if you
develop some debilitating disease over
the next couple years and you're just
like oh my God just put me out of my
misery no we will trap you we're going
to get you that hydrochrome even if we
have to just keep your head alive in a
tank like futur Rama we will do it to
make sure you make it to that's your
gift that's your GI put your head over
here is not letting you die yes your
gift is forced
immortality it's good so yeah happy
birthday Maria love you you've been an
absolute gem in our lives and you you
know damn well that we know that so
thank you my
[Music]
dear